et vous deux vous n'avez pas le droit de
traîner ici je serais curieux de savoir
ce que tu vas faire pour nous virer
tout va bien tout va bien je me suis
juste tordu la cheville
je m'appelle koala man j'ai décidé de
dédier ma vie à nettoyer nos rues
à aider les innocents et à éradiquer le
mal cependant d'herbe fait un demi
centimètre de trop quoi
tu peux réparer la connexion internet
s'il te plaît c'est celui où je retire
le poisson [ __ ] de l'urètre de mon
caméraman j'ai gardé la bestiole
papa est devenu dingue c'est ça il est
impressionnant à vous de jouer griffe
koala oh non ça c'est un gadget que j'ai
pas encore inventé j'ai installé des
caméras dans les toilettes c'est là que
se passe les transactions
Kevin
ils ont tous perdu la boule le bol a été
relâché dans la voiture
voici ma panique c'était pas utile d'en
avoir une si on prévoit pas de paniquer
le bonjour Captain Australia je suis ton
ennemi juré
j'ai parfois l'impression d'être le seul
obstacle qui empêche cette ville de
sombrer dans l'anarchie
[Applaudissements]
tu savais toi qu'on pouvait recommencer
tout de suite on est foutu
de nous filer ton portefeuille sachez
que je maîtrise parfaitement l'art du
karaté pour adulte et je n'attends s'il
vous plaît arrêtez